I've been watching you and you watching  me  My dear Miss everything  make no mistake the game is coming to  its end  for the first time in our life ties were  standing together with 13 districts  our future starts tomorrow and dawn  we march together into the camera so our  advanced president's Knowles building a  minefield of traps the sadistic  inventions of game makers live to make  sport of our deaths ladies and gentlemen  welcome to the submissions Hunger Games  we got one shot  let's make a count  nothing good is safe while he's alive  snow has to pay for what he's done  our lives were never ours  they belong to snow and our deaths due  to  but if you killed him tennis  if you end all of this  they mean something  tonight  turn your weapons  to the capital  turn your weapon  just no  you